avec le nouvel an ce qui est bien chaque
année c'est que les comportements des
gens je sais jamais les mêmes
il ya ce mec relou avec leur jeu panique
et l'ambiance mais pas tout à fait
minuit ont cessé leur de paris là
maintenant il ya toujours ce mec qui
fait un jeu de mots nul avec l'année et
2015 l'année de la brague 2016 l'année
de la drague en 2016 il ya ceux qui
arrivent à la soirée mais un peu trop
tôt bonne année je reviens après je vais
faire un tour en ville il ya ce mec qui
a pas trouvé de soirée salut je
m'appelle bertrand roucas on s'était
croisé une fois dans la cour en co2 rien
n'avait changé d'époque venir il ya ce
mec déçu en arrivant parce qu'il se rend
compte que la soirée est carrément nue
la bonne année
il ya ce mec qui se trompe dans le
décompte 3 2 à 23 heures il ya ces mecs
qui sous prétexte que ces deux nouvelles
en ont vraiment cru qu'il pouvait
ramener leurs 200 potes à toutes les
soirées
salut je suis venu avec 21 postes ça
dérange pas de te barrer de chez toi et
de nous laisser la baraque il ya ceux
qui croient que le sms de bonne année
est vraiment beaucoup plus important que
vivre l'instant présent
voilà voilà enfin t'amuser il ya ceux
qui veulent absolument être originaux en
disant bonne année en anglais sauf qu'il
parle pas très bien anglais à pignoux
christmas il ya toujours ce mec ou cette
meuf relou qui envoie un texto roman
cher ami
après une année à vos côtés et riche en
amitié j'ai le plaisir de vous souhaiter
à tous mes meilleurs voeux les plus
sincères la santé est un trop long on
est tous d'accord pour dire que ce genre
de textos on s'en bat les couilles
après vous je sais pas mais moi ce genre
de textos j'y réponds souvent comme ça
merci personnellement à toi de m'avoir
envoyé ce message qui me touche
particulièrement dans le toit vu
l'amitié qu'on vit tous et moi merci
vraiment on va évidemment tous recevoir
nos sms de bonne année ont décalé à
cause du réseau qui saturent à j'ai reçu
un texto c'est bon bonne année 2012
c'est vraiment décalé il ya toujours ces
numéros inconnus qui t'envoie un sms de
bonne année
il ya ce moment on se fait tous la bise
sans a priori en donnant juste de
l'amour au premier venu et c'est ça qui
est beau claude bertrand vaste et il ya
les gens âgés qui aime bien dire bonne
année en langage de gens âgés fatah et
moi te souhaitons une bonne saint
sylvestre tonton je m'appelle pas
sylvestre il ya évidemment cet universel
blague de mecs un peu lourd
bonjour des bouteilles ou l'année
prochaine c'est à dire dont dix minutes
nos grands parents on les aime à fond tu
vois mais faut bien être qui pourrait
nous appellent à 00h05 pour nous
souhaiter la bonne année
il est quand même un petit changement
d'ambiance ma musique je t'appelle pour
te souhaiter joyeuses années
c'est peut-être la dernière fois que je
le fais
des prochaine je serai peut-être plus là
qui sait d'accord mamie à leur foi et
puis à ce moment où tu te rends compte
que tu passes un réveillon plutôt moyen
quand le premier mec à te souhaiter la
bonne année
c'est lui
je vous rassure je vais pas vous faire
de romans je souhaite à tous une très
très bonne saint sylvestre merci à tous
d'être encore cette année de plus en
plus d'endroits à me suivre à être
abonné à la chaîne youtube vous êtes de
plus de 7 millions bientôt vous êtes
200000 est venu me voir en spectacle
ça fait un peu frais à l'eau de rose
mais je m'en fous je le dis quand même
grâce à vous je fais vraiment un truc
que j'aime je me réveille et je fais un
truc qui me passionne et en plus quand
ça vous plaît c'est dix fois mieux
juste un énorme merci et puis voilà je
nous souhaite à tous une très bonne
année 2016
bon on va pas se mentir à ce qui s'est
passé en france en 2015
je pense que l'année suivante pourra
être que meilleure enfin j'espère du
coup mon seul souhait pour 2016 cinq on
passe tous une très bonne année ou juste
une année normale
voilà merci à tous leurs au max à très
bientôt et surtout à pinho crise menace
de taille 9 au 10 mai qui arrive en 6ème
d'affaires auquel enough
je suis chaud fou si tu avais une
baguette magique